欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好上个礼拜五本来想说大魔王
CPI年增率开出来之后
看到联准会的9月升息几率
已经高达将近90个百分点
反而市场好像不怕咯
夜盘大涨哦
那今天台股再跌哪一条呢
因为今天的盘中一度又跌了将近800点
跌的就是星期天又有AI鬼故事啦
这个OpenAI说它延后挂牌
到底发生什么事
Enthorpic也讲说为了人类好
AI现在发展的太快了
最好大家都降规降速
还有记忆体也有非常多人说
我们现在有新的一些应用方式
记忆体后的用量就不用这么多了
只要剩下八分之一就够了
好没想到六日是科技股的乱流
来打乱了市场
所以今天韩股开低
我们也跟着杀低
但中场我们跌了322点
又留下了一个400多点的下影线
这个礼拜是一个闯关周
这个礼拜各个关卡突破之后
说实话就要迎接第四季了
来宾们说
接下来就是海阔天空的时候
来好好的听起来来欢迎他们
第一位是股市师公永年老师
好到底要闯哪些关呢
礼拜三台指起结算
礼拜四有联准会的会议
禮拜五也有日央到底要不要升息
以及美国的四五日
一关一关一关过完之后呢
到底是不是叫做海阔天空
今天的量能真的缩得好小哦
只有6300多亿施工说
好机会藏在里头
因为我们看到像PCB
八月营收创新高的
几乎全部七一色排出来哦
可是股价却都还没有过高
这就是机会啦
等一下施工帮您点名
继续涨价的PCB
现在等着叙事待发哦
好第二位
是我們的題材獵人漢偉哥
好漢偉哥也要講囉
其實現在升息機率高達90%
市場不怕囉
因為反正伸頭一刀縮頭一刀
那怕什麼
怕的又是AI亂流
現在這些大廠們又出來喊
哎呀大家降龜啊降速啊
AI在發展
超越人類智慧會很不利
其實這是商場的陰謀
今天很多AI股是被錯殺的
包括記憶體哦
等一下來聊這一塊該如何解
當然現在做好資產配置
也很重要
如果手上有一些资金
也可以挪去看看航海王
因为油价往上涨
红海的乱还在乱
运价也在往上冲
航海王没有在动的时候
动起来就一发不可收拾
第三位是我们的冠军操盘手
云翔哥
奇怪了
每个礼拜天大家都在狙击谁
狙击大力光
上礼拜瑞银
这礼拜大摩
大力光今天又杀到跌停板
玉金光也同样被拉到跌停板
但是云翔哥观察转机快来啰
连续外资的降频连续的集叠
往往酝酿着就是后面的V转
等一下教您光学股到底该怎么操作
另外台积电也是受压抑的
台积电供应链厂物工程的大厂们
手上好几千亿订单的
现在也压在这儿
但反而云翔哥告诉你
酝酿到最后极限了
快要表态了到底是哪些公司
好 首先有请永年老师
今天盘6000多亿的成交量
真的已经说到一个
快点啦
到底要做什么的
几块钻
好 台股今天
这个礼拜要过三关
结算啦
刚刚讲到央行的利率决策会议
能不能海阔天空
你看好的还是
营收不但创新高的PCB
是 没有错
我们这个来看一下
这个礼拜要出很多的事情
出很多的事情
对 先看上个礼拜五的时候
美國公佈這個8月份的CPI
那其實都還好
其實都還好
只有核心CPI
它是超過市場的預期
9月升息的機率
立刻從60%跳到86%
那其實86已經非常接近
會升息的這個
那可是當天
大家都嚇一跳
就是說它公佈出來一看
大家有點超過預期然後這個機率上升到86%了這個股市應該要跌了吧结果没有 反而大涨四大指数都大涨收盘之后才讲这个
曼德海辖被控制住了
所以它的这个盘后的电子盘
是跌的
OK 好
那么所以今天晚上
到底会怎么样呢
就变得很重要
变得很重要了 好
那除了今天晚上
美国股市之外
我们再看一下
这第一关是台子级要结算
到今天为止8.2万口
外资的净空单部位
不过今天已经回补了
2313口的空单了
说不定 因为理论上来讲的话
它通常是在礼拜三结算
通常是在礼拜二的卖压会最重
看起来今天他们已经补了一大堆了
明天的卖压可能会比较减轻
这一点大家就可以注意一下
好 再过来就是9月17号的
美国联准会的利率决策
现在看起来大概应该会升息一码
那可是呢我们这样子看
因为市场上的现在解读是说
这两个码一个就不升息一个就升息
那所以他不升息的话
反而大家会说那你这个领准会呢
独立性不见了
对没有错
那所以大家就会不相信他的独立性
那反而不见得是好事
可是升息的话呢
有可能会利空出尽
为什么
因为大家去想想看
它这个上礼拜五呢
大家想说
它的升息的几率超过八成了
结果股市反而没有跌
对不对
对 反而觉得那就这样吧
就算了吧
有点这样的感觉
是不是
那如果到时候呢
中东的这个局势趋缓的话
搞不好呢
就利空出境了
便利多了
对 反而利空出境了
可是呢
现在有一些的事情是这样子
日本的央行呢
它17号 18号
它也可
他这次升息是升定了
升息升定了
那么如果日本央行升息的话
那么日元大家会讲
日元会不会再升值
我觉得不会了
因为他现在已经预先反应了
所以到时候可能不见得会升值了
万一这个日元没有升值了
反而利多出境
他开始贬值的话
再加上如果联准会
他确实有升息的话
一来一往
对 这样的美元会升值
那美元升值的话
对我们股市是比较不利的
因为会进去套汇套利
好 那我们看一下
台湾的这个加权指数
好 那这个月线
你看到目前为止
这个9月份的月线
是留一个上影线
收个小黑 对不对
好 我们万一
它这个月线是收黑的话
也就是简单来讲
这个礼拜的周线
如果是收黑的话
那么9月的月线
就会收黑了
流上影線收黑
那10月呢
繼續往下探底的機會會非常大
還要再探啊
對 就第二次探底
那如果呢 反過來講
如果這個禮拜的週限是收紅的話
那9月份的月線
收紅的機會就很大了
如果9月份收紅的話
我覺得10月份
繼續收紅的機會更大
為什麼
因為10月要公布
那個第三季的財報了
對不對 第三季財報會不會好
一定不錯的啊
對不對 你看那個營收嚇死人了
所以一定會不錯的
所以我觉得9月份的月线收红的话
这个10月份继续收红机会大
也简单的讲
这个礼拜就是一个关键周
非常非常关键的一个周
那我们当然希望它上去
那如果说9月10月月线都收红的话
我觉得应该有机会看到
50,500到52,500点
应该是有机会的
那我们看一下日线图
日线图呢今天很明显
今天是下来测试了这个季线
又拉上去了
对不对拉上去
虽然月线还在上面是形成这个压力
那我们所以我们明天看
我们看明天的话如果它是
今天晚上看看美国
如果今天晚上美国是收黑的话
我们明天可能会收黑
可是呢会不会把今天的下引线完全跌破掉呢
我觉得这个机会不太大
大概就是收个黑
它的低点应该不会超过今天的低点
应该还会继续守住这个季线的今天量需要留意吗今天只剩下6300亿的量因为今天的6300亿其实是4月7号以来的最小量
那还可以接受
那我觉得
对我觉得其实今天的震荡幅度
如果也能缩小到很小的话
是更理想
今天的这个震荡幅度
还嫌太大了一点
如果能缩更小的话
它就变成压缩
就是量价都极度压缩
接下來不是噴出就是跳水
就很刺激了
OK 好
那過來我們看台積電
台積電今天當然一口氣
就跌破了月線跟季線
因為它好黏好黏
這樣算一種表態嗎
OK 好
我們從技術面來看的話
你看它在過去這兩個月
它只要是跌破了
這些所有的移動均線的話
第二天幾乎都立刻就站回去
所以是好機會採燈
其實是有機會啦
是有機會
当然最坏的情况就是他再来下探一次
上一次盘中的低点
这是最坏的情况
不过我还是要讲一下替他喊冤
你看8月份的营收年增率53%
月增率10%
他是连续4个月创地史新高
对不对
然后外资预估2027年EPS143块
现在预估本益比还不到17倍
我记得上个礼拜来的时候
说是他是17倍
现在还不到17倍了
那真的很冤
那所以呢
技术面虽然有出现转弱的疑虑
可是以长期考量的话
我是觉得说
逢低就早买点嘛
是 逢低
如果没有办法
或是不敢一次买的话
就分批买嘛
就定时定额分批买就对了
OK 好 再关联发科了
其实施工非常看好联发科
上次专访施工的时候说
用波浪理论来看
它还有后面一大波
是 對 應該還有個第五波
可是現在它目前為止
還是在第四波裡面
所以我們不排除
它還有再拉回來測試
這個3千5到4千的這個可能性
不排除這個可能性
因為它還可以
這個下來兩個月 上去兩個月
再下來兩個月 再上去
再上去三個月左右
然後再往上衝 是有可能的
所以也不用急著追高
那從日線來看的話
它今天雖然是開低走高
可是還是OK
而且最主要是被这个五日线压着了
那所以呢在操作上
可能稍微的要注意一下
因为它现在成交量是缩小的
那所以呢要突破这上涨的
短期的移动均线
可能会有一点点的这个难度
是
所以大家可以注意一下
就不用急着去追高了
就拉回来的话
再来找买点就好了
我其实蛮早就看好它了
就是因为它那个ASIC晶片
因为没有想到它会在这一方面
它打败了博通
这个是
我一看它打败博通以后
我就开始对它就分外的有好感
是 OK
今天其实ASIC相关概念股在盘面上
是强悍的
像创意 益望等等的
没有错
所以值得注意了
另外台达店大家可能就觉得
怎么搞的会这个样子呢
因为跌太久了
因为从2580跌下来跌很久
跌很久
这次反弹起来其实也弹得不够力
到了季线就被压下来了
那其实最主要的原因是因为
它第三级原物料
特别是那种电源IC它短缺
大家还是挺担心的
对 出货就比较不顺了
好 那我们从技术面来看的话
你看周线来讲的话
它这边是跌下来吗
我们当时有讲过这边是
一二三四五坡跌下来了
然后现在反弹反弹不过季线
再被压回
这里呢守个这个半年线
年线的位置
守个年线位置
它应该守得住
那应该所说的话
这边就变成一个第一只脚
第二只脚
这边就有机会形成一个W底
它只要能守住年线的话
它有机会守住W底
W底的颈线位置在2000块这个附近
所以它是有机会来挑战2000块的
我觉得这支股票
因为它基本面毕竟还是很好的
而且本益比也不高
本益比呢才24倍而已
所以应该是有机会
大家这个看一下
它如果能够守住年线的话都是 我就是覺得說可以注意它的未來的保障但是是不是就需要有點耐性了因為它看起來就是外資投信都一直還沒有辦法回頭部
對 沒有錯
其實我剛剛介紹台積電
這個聯發科還有台達電
這三支股票都是要用
長期的眼光去看的
短線上因為雜音太多了
所以很難說
好 OK
那我們找活潑一點的工具吧
對 這個BCP
你看一大堆的皇冠有沒有看到
创历史新高
没错
营收创历史新高的股票
那这几支股票
京居 建顶 建荣跟腾辉
那他们是呢
他之前前一波创了高
然后这一波并没有创新高
股价还没有创
对 可是一个底部的形态
其实是相当完整的
那这些是可以
那另外呢
像是景硕 新星 台药
台光店 南亚还有富桥
他们是这一波有创新高
股价有创新高
股價創新高了
然後你可以看到
拉回來的速度都很快
就是好像有點假突破的樣子
那可是我們是覺得說
他們的基本面各方面都不錯
所以我們先就是等一下
等它拉回來整理的差不多了
不會再跌了
好 我們再進場
就不用急著進場去搶反彈
好 兩組都不錯
但先做這一組
對 沒有錯
那這一組的話像京居
京居今天盤中的時候
差一點點拉到漲停板
而且它已經又收復了
所有的移動均線
因為它之前有這個
又被關了
關情幣
今天禮拜五的時候
放出來就跌下來了
今天就把上禮拜五的這個跌幅
完全吃掉了
有一點帶量
所以量價是配合的
那技術面上來講的話
我之前講過
這邊它做了一個
類似頭肩底的一個形態
所以上檔又沒有什麼套牢壓力
所以這支股票
技術量可以注意
那麼它上半年的EPS 4.22元
年增率246%
這個我記得它在去年的
全年的EPS好像是4.21元
我應該沒有記錯
它半年就賺盈去年全年了
所以這支股票呢
我還是覺得說可以值得注意的
好
好 再過來是見頂
也是PCB的極優勢
對 好 然後呢
它也是這一波上來以後就
哇 一直盤盤了一個月了
盤了一個月了
那他那一個月是表示他不好嗎
不是
他在這次整理呢
整理他把這些移動經線
全部統統準備糾結到一起去
糾結到一起去的話
而且他一直守在上緣
移動經線上緣
所以技術面來講的話
他是強勢股
那距離他現在距離
他的這個高點
598塊還是有一段距離
快100塊的距離
對 差不多100塊的距離
所以呢
我覺得他現在是沒有量了
只要有量的話
突破這邊的高點
這一根大量的高點的話
那它來挑戰598塊
應該不會有太大問題
這是從技術面來看
基本面當然也不用講了
這個8月份營收首度
突破百億元大關
這個又是在創歷史的新高了
所以這個技術面上來講
基本面來講也沒有問題
好 銅箔基板的連貌
連貌就比較
這個技術面上來講
比較有一點麻煩
基本面有沒有問題
沒有問題
基本面完全沒有問題
技術面這裡有一點
要形成一個頭部的味道
因為它現在創高過了
就是施工講的
創高但現在壓回裝 對
創高再拉回
你現在創高的股票幾乎都拉回了
所以拉回來
它是要整理以後再上
還是就此沉淪下去
這個要值得觀察
這些股票值得觀察
那麼可是我是覺得說
它只要它這邊左腳的位置
左肩的位置大概是在478塊
它只要不跌破478塊的話
其實還是有機會翻回來的
那萬一跌破478塊
就要注意它可能會下探季線
可能會下探季線
季線的位置大概在415塊這個附近
那就要稍微的注意一下
好 同樣都跟銅箔相關
不過金居的話應該是可以轉價
銅的上漲
聯貿這些可能目前
大家都觉得成本有点压力
对 它比较有压力
是
好 今天非常谢谢永连老师
谢谢